はいみなさんこんにちはどう件ですずっと今日は a
いつもと全然違うことをやります
でまぁ具体的に何をしますするかと言いますと
今日は a 台本を使いませんで
編集とかを使って自分の日本語のおかしいところを
厚膜隠したりごまかすたりとかもしませんので自分の日本語のおかしいところがその
まま
動画に残ります
ぜひチェックしてくださいチェックチェックしてください
はいで今日の動画のんえええ
ポイントテーマを何かと言いますと題名にあるように
道元の日本語はなぜおかしいのかについてこれについて話してみたいと思います
以前は例えばへな魚がおかしいとかへ
フォアアクセントもおかしいとかあとなんだかな
口をもうちょっと開けて話した方がいいとかまぁこれについて結構話してたと思うん
ですが今日はそういう指摘できるところではなく
指摘しづらい自分の日本語のおかしいところについて話した話してみたいと思います
で
そのまあ指摘しにくいところについてなんですが多く
北年に34回ぐらい日本人の視聴者
視聴者たちから a 同件はまあ日本を結構上手い方だけどなんかおかしい
見ててなんか
うまく説明できないけど何か引っかかるところがあります
でそれはなん言えないけど説明できないけどたしかなんかあります
こういうコメント a はい定期的にもらってますで僕も結構長い間
結構気になってたんですが最近はやっとその
答えがわかったっていうかアレ
分かったようなような気がしてきたんので辺境の動画を作ることにしました
でまぁ結論から言いますと多分多分多分なんですけどねこれは全然自分の日本語は本当
は完璧ですよとか全然そういうつもりは全くなくて
モスクワ自分の日本語完璧でもなんでもないと思ってるんで
今日の動画は会で何が言いたいかというと
com に動画の日本語はなんであんなに不自然なのか
まあこれについて話してみたいと思います結論から言いますと
台本があるからだと僕は僕は思っていますっていうのを
台本があってその中に台詞ぐ
曲セリフがあるじゃないですかそのセリフを上
読み上げる前に
今そのままで例えばその書く言葉のパックセントとかをチェックしたり
まあこういう言い方をこうした方がいいだろうなぁとか思いながらチェックするんです
よね毎回毎回
で飼っ覚醒リーフを10回ぐらい読み上げるんですがその
10回の中の一番良いと個人的に思ってるやつを選んで動画のその編集していますいつ
も
で逆に
台本があってそのセリフの正
正しいと僕は思っているえええ
発音とか言い回しとか言い回しじゃないんですけどいいかパ
があるから
それを言おうとする自分が
a 変えて自分の日本語のを不自然にしてると思うんですよね
っていうのは今こうやってえまあ台本なしに話してるじゃないですか
でまぁ比較的に t 話になるんですがっていう話なんですが
いつものコミュに動画と比べて少しはこの方が自然じゃないですか
まあ少なくとも僕はそう思ってるんですけど本当はそうじゃないかもしれないんですが
このに動画の方では台本があってかこのセリフを
ここにアクセントをこういようと思っている
その絵もその自分の姿勢が買えて
自分の発音不自然にししていると思うんですっていうのは
なんか変に力が入ったり
何だろうこうやって話してると正しい形なんてないじゃないですか
なのでそので校多いついた言葉をそのまま言うだけなんですが
フェリーフってなった時は a
多摩正しい言い方があると思っているからこそ
不自然になるんですよねいつも僕はうーんも同じことを何度も何度もここでこの部分で
言ってるんですが
例えば皆さんこういう経験ありませんか例えば
スピーチコンテストに出ることになりましたとか
ま友達がスピーチコンテストに出ることになりましたで
自分もそこその友達とカーンが普段から使っているへ英語
まあ結構自信を持って話したりできるんですができるんですが
スピーチコンテストのいざとなった時は何か何かおかしい
大げさすぎるていうか何かでやっぱり力が入りすぎててそれによっていつもの
いつもの自然な
英語がなんか不自然になっちゃったみたいな
へ
経験ありませんか
もうそれに見たような現象なんじゃないかなと僕はね個人的に思っています
勝手なええっ
推測です推測に過ぎませんが a
ここで言いたいのは少なくともコミュに動画の中にある日本語よりは今の日本語の方が
いい
自然自然じゃないですか
だといいんですがデコに動画の日本がないとやっぱり比較できないと思うんで
このに動画じゃなくてもいいけど台本の日本語と今の日本語
やっぱり比較したほうがいいかなと思うんでこれから今からで自分が
ずっと前に書いた文書親父マグネット ok のまてぃ文章の文章の冒頭を読み
あげようと思っています朗読してみようと思っています
はいえー
[拍手]
はいあります
日本の人口の99.99%は日本人である
そのうちの8割はに従来の女性でその8割のうちの75%は練習を積んだ細身の
バレリーナで残りは健康美に輝く看護婦とモーニング娘や akb48などといった
はいど
のグループのメンバーである
国民のほとんどは外国人を見たことはおろか
町で見かけたことすらないそのため多くの女性は異国の男性にばったり出会うと途端に
ひざまずいて毎晩お寿司を握ってあげるから私を妻にしてと懇願する
興奮のあまり思わず男に飛びついてしまうものも
少なくないこういった絶え間ないナンパ攻撃を退けるために
外国人男性はみんな普段からバットを持ち歩く
インターネットの情報はいつも希望に満ちあふれている
しかし残念ながら現実はそうでもない
2012.3.24ぽくは親友の結婚式に参列するために一週間ほどの予定でアメリカ
に帰った
以下はその日僕が大分の田舎にある子
学校出てからし後のシアトルの空港に着くまでの記録である
それと同時に日本在住の外国人男性が日々
無言で立ち向かっている本当の恐怖についての文書でもある
ん
8:45am 老いた犬のド田舎にある三重町の駅でこれからの長旅
これからの長旅ん長旅に備えてモンスターエナジーをすすりながら僕は今にも壊れて
しまいそうなプラスチックベンチに座って大分行きの列車を待っている
30人ほどのモーニングラッシュが終わったところでお役に
的にいるのは寝坊してしまった高校生と腰の曲がった老人だけだ
つまりのベンチでは白髪の女性が読書に夢中になっている
空は晴れそよ風が吹いている
自然に囲まれたこの小さな役は静かである
根本だしてしまえばいいの
がきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅのハイパー音楽を聴きつつ
カフェインたっぷりのモンスターを飲んでいる僕にはその静けさが全く味わえない
列車到着まで3分
うんポーンウェイーぽんぽん a ぽんぽーん
到着まで1トン
冷たい感を再び口にするとその時視界に入る小さな赤いしかっけー
到着時間が迫るにつれてその4カップ以下下がどんどん大きくなり
列車のかたちをとってくる
うぇいうぇーい開けて私の道を
列車が聞いいと音を立ててキャリーの公園打ち消したからホームに走り込み
そして眠そうな高校生を何か吐き出す
カメラの間をすり抜けて列車に列車に乗り込むと僕はリュックを下ろして橋この座席に
腰掛ける
独尊に夢中の老女は文字から目を外すことなく多くの方に向かって歩いていく
まもなく出発いたします
よす涙岡部て結構も仕込んでくる
パイ泥はいないけれどこれから1時間ほど
が家で勉強ができる村上隆のセクティナ宴を開く前に僕は眼を瞑ってやまぬ山の
すがすがしい空気を肺いっぱい吸い込んだ
はいしまった最後の所へちょっとまあ間違いました
なんだったかなぁ
え
こわいないけるぞこれから1時間ほどが家で勉強ができる
じゃないじゃないわちょちょっと待ってよなんだったかなぁ
a
結婚を申し込んでくるアイドルがいないけれどこれ
モンスターいなー g と小説それからきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅとオンス音質の良い
イヤホンは持っている
これから1時間ほどが家で勉強ができるう村上隆のセクティナイフ100前に僕は眼を
瞑って山の山の姿がすがすがしい空気を肺いっぱい吸い込んだ
でした間違えました母
残念で
え
まあ今ど朗読ジャン演技 star star star じゃないですか
多分淫技やってる方が文っ張りなんか変に地区力が入ってるとか
こんなんだろう
いつものそこまで気にならないへ
だ行の発音と彼が演技の中だとやっぱり力が入っているそれがよりへ大きくなるから
もっと不自然に聞こえるとかそういうのが少なくてもあったと思います
でまぁもしくはこれも a 仲間た僕にとってすごくいい
なん
なかなか直せないところなんですがええ声が急に低くなったりへ
港へパンティんでしたっけ
びよんびよんびよんだと温かな花ノートになったりとかしてたじゃないですか
それなんて買って言って米動画の中では a
そういうキャラクター登場登場人物が
a でるからなんですよね例えば市役所の人が嫌なのでわざとちょっと嫌な言い方に
する
このような言い方にするとかまあ
サラリーマンと母の演技をする時は
あ山本さんロン牌のーしーですどうですか最近
とかやってたと思うんですよね以前の会10年前の日本語の動画ではねっ
なので今まで
作ってきた a 登場人物
に無意識になりきろうとするんですよね
なぜか自分のそうでない動画の中でもそれ何でかって言ってやっぱりその演技の
スイッチが入るからだと思うんですよね
まあこれも推測なんですが今自分が話している日本語
だよの中にその急に低くなったりとか変ヴィヴィオになったりとか
ない山へですか
だからねまあやっぱり子なんか関係あると思うんですよねその平易に演技とは
でまあ
え
比較
どどうでしたかやっぱりへ演技んやってる方が自然不自然
じゃなかったですかまあ多分皆さん
ねえ思ってるんじゃないかなと僕は思っています
でまぁ今日の動画もう多分15分くらいになってて
カットとかも今まで一切してないから
うな今日の動画の言いたかったえええんぎー
をしていない方のこの日本語の方が自然だっていう人1視聴できたかな
ができたかなと
糧に勝手に思っていますでもうこのあたりで
をすでに自分が今まで何度も何度もイッたことをすでに繰り返して言ってるカラーも
切った方がいいと思います
はいえ
近いうちに親父マグネットもう1回へ行ってみようかなと思っています
僕かなりこの文章が好きなんですよね
やっぱり長いんでえ
で
まあこれも次回について話してみたいと思うんですが
a
やっぱり好きな文章なのでうまくやりたいんですよね
何かあっあーっうまくできなかったらすごいもったいないんじゃないかなと思うんです
よねこの分今まで書いてきた文章の中で一番出来がいい
かっナンディんでしたっけ会心の出来会心の出来て言うんでしたっけはいええ
ここできた方がいいですよねなので動画を切りますありがとうございましたありがとう
ございますこれからもよろしくお願いします以上
大方のない道間でした
ん ni